servus skills und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video wie manche von euch
vielleicht gesehen haben hat steht die
wm ich gestern geträumt haben zur schule
gefällt haben bei unserem ersten versuch
die antwort zu spielen und mega viele
haben unter dem letzten kommentierte
steger jährlich betreut
deswegen dachte ich es wird euch
vielleicht interessieren so zu sehen wie
die aufnahme bei uns außer weil ich das
auch aufgenommen habt habe ich auf
twitter gefragt und mega viele von euch
wurden dass wir sehen deswegen wie ihr
wollt das ist euer video und film ab für
meine version von sticky macht scheiße
und wir kriegen es nicht mit
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video hier sollte auch timo
ja mit wenig und wir spielen eine map
gehäuse skw die kraft von ben 13 24 6
wir sind einfach hier draufgegangen
dachten zurückkommt schauen wir mal was
da so gibt und es gibt tatsächlich es
gibt drei maps für wenige und mich baut
mehr aber es gibt nur maps für für dich
und mich
es gibt nicht mehr für mich im max nicht
mehr ziemlich und luca und nicht maps
für mich
1239 ordner fachmann strafferes das
gibst dich mal ich hab keinen sprung
bist du ein bisschen ich wusste gleich
dass man bei dieser map hintenrum muss
ich doch man muss da vorne rum
was also von dieser unter leiter auf die
oberleitung sprengmeister
ich versuche mal aufzuholen kannst du
noch schaffen meinst du das ist möglich
lotto einiges
das bist du es bist du bist meine immer
ein echter meine hautfarbe oder gibt es
widersprüche hallo leute ist drei
kammern vergleich mal das dann hier da
da da das eigentlich mich ähnlich
willkommen wie die dann lasst uns
loslegen den job und 321 gespielt und
auf meiner schulter der open weißen
pfeil zeigt mir ich muss da lang auf
meiner schulter runter was ist das
basket bälle oder was ist das hier wie
volvo befassen quartal 8 megawatt
software gebaut hat eigentlich gut zu
wissen es ist aber weiter kleiner ich
sagte sich rosenquarz rosenquarz macht
immer unterhosen schwarz
das ist nicht sehr wichtigen leitsatz
von leben hier ab springer auf die
schulter was los geht's
400 ist voller das volle punktzahl für
kreativität er wieder dran
ja ich bin ich bin streng ich habe schon
besseres besiegten
ok dann machen wir einfach noch eine
merkwürdig sagen was klar so leute sind
wir wieder timo liudger world und wir
haben hier eine map der ssg wenig kraft
20 inspiration wenig 2321 kann man sich
irgendwie unsichtbar machen wenn du ein
platten zu verkaufen
dann bist du nur bei drei platten
abstand unsichtbar was die leute nicht
in die quere hätte eigentlich gar nciht
ob sowas geht aber auf war klar dass auf
die mode spieler eingerichtet wurden
schauen oder ein team auf jeden fall ist
so gut gemacht ist aber dass das heißt
dass das geht doch 11 worte [ __ ] ich
scheiße gerade vor ein unterfahrt ja ich
auch maniche gehen einfach davon
das hast du hast das du bist ja nun von
mirbach so optimal darf nicht spenden
zukommen
dass vertreter niemals im leben welche
weiterkommen zu vergessen jeweilig
stehen bis an mein lebensende vielleicht
auf die folge werden ein jahr also
maximal ein jahr will ich sagen guckt
dieser sprung jemand was ist das
interessant
was ist das nicht noch mal
nachdem man diese ganzen scheiß gemacht
hat das ist richtig trick wie man ist
deshalb ist er ohne witz
das geld das geld ja ich gar nicht so
erhält der allergrößte fan von von fans
springen
13 26 aber okay alter vertrag und um die
ecke wo das streak jemand bitte linien
lieben wirst dasteht irgendwas so
stiftung ist richtig denn weil der mann
heißt nenne ich bin jetzt gerade runter
von diesem orangen clay
jetzt bin ich in diesem komischen
labyrinth der fast ganz verschwunden
wegen der unsichtbarkeit aber ich will
ich jetzt mal sehen kann ich mal wieder
an
hey jetzt richtig klausmann teams an
neumann fakten kroos wieder habe ich
gebraucht acht minuten acht minuten
danke dafür leute wenn ihr irgendwelche
maps bauen wollte ich mit einer youtube
anspielt zum beispiel mit wenig hat
jetzt gebaut die und wir finden dann
einfach das halt einfach es sei wenig
rein dann finden wir die erste folge
jobs hat euch gefallen so weit okay dann
sehen wann ich wieder ein bis dann
macht's gut und